[Music]
bow in dallas texas
hey bo welcome to the show
hi appreciate it thanks for having me on
absolutely how can we help
so
i'm 23 i've been working a job for about
10 months out of college make good money
make about 78 000 a year in a couple
months i should be getting a raise
anywhere from 90 to 100. i've always
been pretty uh
pretty good saving my money for about
past five years i've got about twenty
thousand in a fidelity account
fifteen thousand in bitcoin which i know
you guys are gonna you know give me the
lamp face about
maybe not but and then about five
thousand in a company for one k with a
match but my question is i only have
about three thousand dollars in my
checking account and in the inflationary
environment wherein you know i'm losing
my purchasing power every day just
keeping the money in my checking account
and you know i'm 23 single don't really
think i need to save up for a house in
this crazy housing market should i be
concerned about having the slow amount
of cash in my checking account you know
if an emergency comes up i could just
you know sell some of my stock or some
my bitcoin so that's kind of my question
should i you know
uh keep my cash balance low and keep the
aggressive investing up or maybe you
know try and uh beef up that checking
account yeah i mean it's a great
question um
you know i always answer these questions
that if i woke up in your shoes
and for me having liquid cash just to
get where there's no strings attached
there's no hoops i have to jump through
hurdles i have to get over that i can
just literally get it right now if i
needed it
it gives me a sense of peace and if
there's something that happens that you
have to have cash
having something just available that's
not tied up in investments or even
bitcoin
i really do recommend so that's kind of
our three to six months worth of
expenses when we talk about baby step
three do you have any debt at all are
you completely debt free
no i'm debt-free i was lucky enough i
didn't have to pay for college
you know my only big expense so yeah i'm
debt-free very cool you're doing an
incredible job bo i mean the questions
you're asking at 23 is it's impressive
so
if i were you yeah i would i would have
some money and you can even start saving
for it now if you want um you know and
just saying hey i'm on baby step three
and then start saving for that fully
funded emergency fund um you could do
that because if you if you love this
other stuff that you have your money in
but i would probably just cash out um
one of those investments probably the
bitcoin i know you're not shocked that
i'm gonna say that's not doing great
anyways bo let's be honest
yeah thank you but here's what i'm
thinking why can't you do both why not
have a fully funded emergency fund and
be investing so i think right now your
next goal should be to beef up your
savings uh leave that money in checking
and create a three to six months
expenses savings account and then you
can begin investing fifteen percent
beyond that start saving up for a house
is that your next goal
yeah i think eventually that's the route
i want to go to my like my one thing
with that is i know you know investing
at a young age is so much more important
than investing later on and with you
know the market taking such a big hit
right now i think you know it's just
such a great opportunity to keep you
know in like uh really aggressively
investing at this age yeah and it is so
and i even love the framework that you
have when it comes to the market because
a lot of people are panicked and freaked
out and they don't want to put money in
when you're in a position
that you're in with no debts and you
have you know soon an emergency fund
that's where the perfect time to be
investing aggressively so yeah you're
exactly on the right track bo i don't
think that you're gonna
go wrong anywhere here i would i would
though have some money liquid
just in case something happens you're
able to get to it quickly to your
question bo you were saying that the
liquid cash scares you because it's not
beating inflation but the purpose of the
emergency fund is not to be an
investment it's insurance and so
insurance protects what you're trying to
build and so i'm totally okay with your
emergency fund not being invested and
just sitting in a boring savings account
making you one percent i'm totally good
with that because when an emergency hits
i don't want you dipping into your
investment accounts to cover that i want
you to cover that with your emergency
fund that's what it's there for so i
like keeping things neat and tidy and
separate so that way no one gets
confused here and uh to your question of
investing aggressively you're gonna be a
multi-millionaire just based on the
numbers you told me if you don't
lifestyle creep enter your life as you
get this raise you keep living on less
than you make you invest i also know
there's other goals it's not all about
investing you have to live your life
you've got to go on vacations you're
going to want to upgrade the car you're
going to want to buy a house so balance
it a little bit i can tell with young
investors rachel which i love i know
they can they tend to get real tunnel
vision when it comes to investing and
that's all they think about well that's
a good point because and it's easy to
because you see the math and like what
he said he's like i know investing early
on is so much better because you see
compound interest so you see the math
you see the dollar signs in your eyes
you're like heck why would i do anything
else except for put money in because of
what it could do with compound interest
but you don't factor in life into the
equation and who knows bo you can meet a
girl tomorrow and you kind of fall in
love and you're going to want an
engagement ring you know i'm saying like
anything can happen in life
and having money there
uh is huge and having it as part of your
life strategy knowing that yes while
investing is exciting and the earlier
start the better off you're going to be
all of that
but there's also life
with the numbers you shared bo i'm
seeing a lot of what i assume is single
stocks in the fidelity account
potentially uh and bitcoin and a little
bit in the 401k i would flip-flop that
and lean into the 401k invest in good
gross stock mutual funds and then if you
want to play with some crypto or single
stocks on the side that's fine but i
don't want it to be a large portion of
your net worth because they are way more
volatile than your mutual funds yeah
when your whole retirement
uh if all of your retirement is in
bitcoin which i know bose isn't but
that's that's not a great plan not a
great plan agreed